oh don't mind me just super stressed out
hi eyes I'm here with my brother Tim
hello everyone how are you they can't
actually respond to you oh yes they can
tears in town and I thought that it
would be great one to make a video with
them yes I agree with that statement and
to when you are hosting someone usually
you have to feed them and the greatest
thing in my life right now is that Dan
King come show yourself Diane I met
Diane today she seems like a winner
Diane and I've been working together for
a few weeks we started watching videos
on YouTube about Americans eating
British candy British kids eating
Australian candy and she told me that
Koreans have the weirdest snacks of all
and so I said prove it and so today Tim
and I via Diane will be trying some
Korean snacks today and tried to tell me
that there's three categories here but
first I'm not Korean Korean I'm Korean
American from California the three
categories of ones just like real sex
like being in store snacks and I know
you'll guys will probably like okay
actually was like old cream people
snacks like old timey American candy
yeah and that's about 90 candies like
that guy America through the World War
two Funyuns versus Werther's yes go
ahead up orders somewhere having
Werther's third is a drink in dessert
right I'm ready
let's do that Dan's going to hand us the
snack and Tim and I are going to try and
guess what it is
get it out now sorry four times a day I
choked on my own spit we have really
cute cute cups in case it's necessary
can I just
this this bag full of snacks for us to
try and also there's something in a
freezer that were spoken drives the
first product this looks like these
cakes this looks like yes I'm sort of
rice top of rice oh yeah
Korean cracker oh oh it's in English I
thought I could read Korean [ __ ] Cheers
yes oh yeah
this was like a product cleanser I have
like I'm eating calories away on to the
next one what though Jesus prepared
shredded squid no that's a solution to
the old 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea
movie smells like 20,000 Leagues up it
whoo they should make that perfume this
is what old people eat while watching TV
like what kind of TV like they're
watching the movie hostile I went over
in it the equivalent of like beer nuts
oh there's a lot of it yeah oh oh it's
really good they know what they're doing
my transition to being a Korean older
man it's going to be very smooth onion
flavored rings I have high expectations
Cheers
great blend up next okay it's good
homerun ball choco flavor oh this sounds
delicious
it's a child winking it also looks like
an American child what's the deal with
that it also looks like it could be a 50
year old man we know who the source of
capitalism is we're gonna cater to those
who knows what homerun ball actually
I think there's chocolate inside yeah
that's its motto
I've been Chris shotgun inside quite a
bit work there kind of like a dessert
combos yeah yeah yeah very apt
description grace I wish I could just
morph into this like thank you that's
actually a for telling you get I spasms
oh my god damn they're moist is fruit
cake house rice cake rice sugar salt
green bean sesame mugwort sweet pumpkin
and gravy so mugwort is a spontaneous
bourbon plant
I've been identifying a lot of weeds
around Boston like a big fan of mugwort
it sounds like a Harry Potter character
yeah he died in the fifth book I'm gonna
try the green one I'm gonna try to
purple it's like gushers but they
decided to replace the sweetener it's
with like a ground amoebas own
description of food it's definitely not
bad but it was very much unexpected I
expected sweet but not I think this is
yeah this is solid I found a donor Howie
did you start this yeah it's like a
sweet tree like your grandma would give
that to after dinner or something as a
punishment
you can cleanse your palates we're gonna
give you gonna cleanse palate with the
soda a milky soda it is rice wine oh now
you know oh yeah
six percent alcohol you know this is
like the Arbour mists of Korea
you don't really drink this from a bowl
actually at dinner yes oh it's creative
delicious you uh what is this another
liquid now this is not alcohol this is
for the kids so the kid version
basically measuring it's the virgin
what's a call milk kiss milk kiss like
when you're feeling romantic with your
partner
stop it shut it down I'd like a milk you
oh oh it's like Shasta this is Korean
Shasta no Shasta's Korean milkis yeah oh
my stomach is feeling many things so
this is the one where I have to warn
them before they even try it
it says Korean sausage but I'm telling
you pretend that it's um pork blood
sausage so it's intestine
what you don't have to try it you can
smell it you can observe it but I'm
cooking you don't cook it you can eat it
straight up I like it
what is it warm it's one why is it one
because it's supposed to be more cuz
it's meat oh thank god so is it edible
like the tree in my front yard is edible
like I can technically put it inside my
mouth yeah actually help onboard with
this right so let's just there's a brush
in there right this on me oh not right
there's some guts that some rice types
of dirt you would think that you're
eating rice and then someone got to its
guts did you ever like go to the bait
and tackle section like the Walmart got
it down okay and make this a food dye
Animas Forks
you know how in New York you get in your
car dogs that like cars and stuff yeah
this is
food is a street food no it's fine wait
wait it's spicy rice cake it's really
tough oh I wash it down with some squid
last thing
oops the frozen thing a frozen thing so
this is something that whenever I go to
Korea I would always get at the local
convenience store so they're basically
like creme popsicles in the bush Bob did
you get my haircut I rubbed it in so you
can't get it up captures that I'm into
good Diane thank you so much for you
chose to Korean snack foods
thank you give me like two hours to
decide if I really want to thank you for
this make sure you guys go check out my
brother on his social media platforms
wait what do I still have those yeah
rage and botanist Twitter like find out
the details from there who knows maybe I
won't tweet anything for two months
that's a thing I do then maybe I'll
tweet two hundred things in five minutes
yeah leave a comment down below if you
are into that kind of thing like the
video if you're into that kind of thing
subscribe if you're into that kind of
thing otherwise I don't know everything
smells salty